Molly McGrath was the sideline reporter
and once you realize that this is a big
story that's when her job really begins
because now you're finding out you know
is the potential number one pick in the
draft gonna play football again and I
asked for it I said would you reach out
to ESPN see if we could get Molly on
because I thought she did a great job
and Molly joins us now Molly thanks for
joining us
where were you when - a first went down
with that injury thank you so much for
having me on Dan I was actually on
Alabama's sideline when he went down
with the injury I was standing kind of
next to Alabama's coaching box on the
sideline and I watched just a series of
events unfold as I saw Mack Jones the
backup warming up to go into the game
I saw the team huddle right in front of
me with tua in the middle and Mack Jones
kind of on the periphery and Nick Saban
comes in to a talks to Nick Saban and I
see Mack Jones go back onto the sideline
and lead the huddle so in that moment I
kind of I alerted my producer I said I
don't think Matt Jones is going in it
looks like - is saying Matt Jones is
back on the sidelines and then of course
we see two of go out onto the field and
then that tragic axe accident that that
freak injury happened so I was on
Alabama sideline witnessing that - went
down closer to the Mississippi State
sideline so I crossed over to the other
side of the field to just get a better
vantage point to get closer to try to
hear what the trainers were saying to
him to look into - with I see the pain
that he was in and just tried to figure
out what is the injury the first thing
and the only thing I knew at that moment
was it he had no weight on that right
leg and of course he had just had
surgery weeks ago in his right ankle so
that was of the biggest concern what did
you see and hear from - um in in that
moment I saw a ton of pain he was is he
saying anything I couldn't hear what he
was saying they were talking really
closely to him I had to give enough
space right to give a little to give
respect and to give enough space so that
they can do their job so I was on the
sideline part I wasn't on the field but
I could hear them you know talking very
close
his face was bleeding his nose was
bleeding and there was concern at first
like what's going on with his face why
is he bleeding from his face and he had
you know a towel covering his face and
they kept that on his face longer than
needed and I could see it was because he
was crying because he was kind of
bawling in pain so I knew that he was in
serious pain and they lift him up they
put him on the cart and the cart just
goes straight down the field and I knew
that it was crucial that I be there for
when they take him off the cart because
I needed to see how he got off the cart
if he was able to put weight on his
right leg or the right side of his body
or if he had to be carried so the cart
goes down the field and I sprinted the
length of the field from the ten through
the other end zone
basically on the field pass Joe Moorhead
who I heard say something like whoa
sorry coach as I run the length of the
field go into that that tunnel that led
to the x-ray room and that was the
crucial moment that I witnessed where he
couldn't get off of the cart on his own
medical training staff had to pick him
up and carry him almost like a child and
when they picked him up that's when he
was screaming in pain and then they
brought him into the x-ray room and I
got from a source close with the team
that it was his hip not his ankle so it
was amazing to get all of that so
quickly so that we went to break with
the to injury we were able to come back
right away with the news that it was his
hip that he's an extreme amount of pain
and that he's going for x-rays yeah and
you got it you got to grab what you can
grab it you got to be fair to the
situation you can't speculate you know
so be when they when they're gonna throw
it down to you go I think he may have
it's got to be I'm being told and you
know you've got like three or four
minutes to kind of cobble all this
together and go on live TV with an
injury that you know could affect
Alabama's entire season so that's why I
marvel at that because you're trying to
find this out in real time and you know
just trying to figure out because
there's chaos there and then even the
Alabama people don't know exactly they
took him to Mississippi State's end of
the the stadium that's when I knew they
probably have you know
better medical facilities down there or
more medical facilities that's the one
thing I thought in the moment it's
really really serious if they were
headed there maybe that didn't factor in
Molly but I did think that when I saw
that they were taking him in that
direction yeah well I knew that there
was an x-ray room through that tunnel
and and I knew that they were going on
the other side of the tunnel as an
ambulance
so that was the first thing okay they're
taking him to an x-ray room they're
probably going to take him to an
ambulance this time around and I covered
- its first injury this season his right
ankle injury against Tennessee and you
know I had heard rumblings that he was
leaving in an ambulance during that game
and I ran outside of the stadium and did
circles on the periphery of the stadium
looking for his ambulance so I wasn't
going to let that happen again
so we had eyes on the ambulance we dies
on the x-ray room obviously wanting to
be respectful and give space to the
athlete but also wanting to answer
questions that people have about one of
the most important players in college
football you know time is of the essence
in these things and people at home are
wondering what happened though I felt
like it was crucial that I be there in
that tunnel that I see what I saw when
they had to lift him up off of the cart
and that I got the information that it
was his hip not his ankle I think that
was the most important news of the day
and nick saban confirmed it right after
in my interview with him that it was a
hip injury I think that took everyone by
surprise and you know all this is
happening I'm like trying to calm myself
down as I get all of this information
trying to put it together in my head
telling my producer you can come back to
me out of break I have I have
information I can give and then trying
to calm myself down so I can interview
one of the greatest coaches of my time
you know to interview Nick Saban and ask
him some really tough questions and you
could just see the the despair on his
face when I was talking to him that was
a really a really tough interview but I
think Nick Nick handled it really well
we're talking to Molly McGrath ESPN
college football college basketball
sideline reporter when did you decide
what were you were going to ask Saban
and those always difficult you know
ending the
half you know coming off the field
yeah so before to his injury the
question in my mind was when are you
going to take two out like are we going
to see him at all in the second half
after the injury of course everything
changed and I've worked with Nick Saban
before I believe I have a good rapport
with him and he is very respectful when
you ask the right questions and I've had
great interactions with them so I knew
that I needed its I said this to John
Walters with the athletic it's the same
thing as the coaches say you need to
know your personnel I'm going to ask
question questions differently to Nick
Saban then I would to Mike Leach and
then I would to Tom Izzo so I knew for
Nick Saban my first question had to be
something broad where I could let him
give me what he had if it was something
to the effect of what can you tell us
about to us because in the past with his
right ankle injury when I asked a
question like that she gave me a good
amount of information when you give him
the floor he'll be honest so he gave
information that it was the right hip
they don't know how serious it is but it
could be serious and then the follow-up
was the tricky part and I talked to my
producer you know beforehand and he said
are you gonna ask him why he left to end
and I said yes but I'm gonna frame it
differently because you don't want to
put a coach on the defensive it has fun
especially after such an emotional
moment and you can see kind of the shock
on Nick's face and watching it back you
know you could see how upset he was so
I'm glad I didn't ask him a question
that would make him feel defensive
instead I used what I saw on the field
and what we put in our broadcast to
support my question I said you know we
saw Mack Jones warming up did to a lobby
to stay in and that was my way of asking
whose decision was it to keep 2a in the
game yeah and I applaud you for that
because that was that was the tough and
that's the money question right there
that's as tough as it gets in our
business where he's just lost a
transcendent player and has no idea the
severity
and he wants to go in and regroup and
check on Torah and your job is to stare
it down and ask two questions and let
him go so I applaud you on that mall
that was great stuff and continued
success and we appreciate your time
thank you so much for having me on I
really appreciate it and hi to the
Danette all right Molly McGrath and how
about that a shout out to the dance for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]